Act now.
>> Bill: FOX NEWS ALERT.
19 PAST THE HOUR.
GETTING RARE INSIGHT INTO THE
EARLY DAYS OF THE PANDEMIC NOW
AFTER NEWLY RELEASED EMAILS
LINKED TO DR. ANTHONY FAUCI.
AMONG THEM MANY REVELATIONS.
HIS CORRESPONDENCE WITH A KEY
FIGURE WITH THE WUHAN LAB.
HE THANKED FAUCI FOR DOWN
PLAYING THE COVID LAB LEAK
THEORY EARLY ON IN APRIL OF
LAST YEAR NOW.
IT COMES AS MANY MAJOR NEWS
OUTLETS ARE ACKNOWLEDGE THEY
ORIGINALLY DISMISSED THAT
POSSIBILITY.
DAVID ASHER, A SENIOR FELLOW
HUDSON INSTITUTE.
PART OF THE STATE DEPARTMENT
INQUIRY INTO THE ORIGINS OF
COVID THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN SHUT
DOWN EARLIER THIS YEAR.
WELCOME BACK TO OUR PROGRAM AND
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
GOING TO READ THIS LINE.
DAVID -- PETER IS HIS NAME FROM
BRITAIN.
HE SENT THIS EMAIL IN APRIL
LAST YEAR.
JUST WANTED TO SAY A PERSONAL
THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF OUR
STAFF AND COLLABORATORS FOR
PUBLICLY STANDING UP AND
STATING THAT THE SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE SUPPORTS A NATURAL FOR
COVID-19 FROM A BAT TO HUMAN
SPILLOVER, NOT LAB RELEASE FROM
THE WUHAN INSTITUTE OF VIROLOGY.
YOUR COMMENTS ARE BRAVE AND
COMING FROM YOUR TRUSTED VOICE
IT WILL HELP DISPEL THE MYTHS
BEING SPUN AROUND THE VIRUS’S
ORIGIN AND FAUCI RESPONDED.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR KIND NOTE.
SO FAUCI DISMISSED THIS EARLY
ON AND PRETTY MUCH SAID SO
PUBLICLY.
HOW DO WE LOOK BACK ON THAT NOW
13 MONTHS LATER?
>> HE WAS RIGHT TO DISMISS IT
BECAUSE SEEMS TO BE WORKING FOR
SOME OTHER POWER IN SOME
BIZARRE WAY.
I DON’T HAVE ANY PROOF OF IT
BUT HE WAS TWEETING ON DECEMBER
31st OF 2019 THAT THIS WAS
COMING OUT OF A LAB OR
SOMETHING TO THAT EFFECT.
HE IS A GUY WHO IS AN
EPIDEMIOLOGIST WHO LOVES
EPIDEMICS AND I GUESS WE
SHOULDN’T BLAME HIM.
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO CARE ABOUT
THESE THINGS.
THEY’RE SERIOUS.
THIS IS A CASE WHERE WE
PROBABLY HAD AN EPIDEMIC THAT
WAS MOST LIKELY CAUSED BY HUMAN
GAIN OF FUNCTION, NOT BY NATURE.
AND HE NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT
CAREFULLY BY THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT.
>> Bill: TO BE CLEAR HERE
FAUCI’S RESPONSE IS QUOTE IT’S
TOTALLY CONSISTENT WITH THE
JUMP OF A SPECIES FROM AN
ANIMAL TO A HUMAN.
A LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE SAID IT
IS TOO EARLY TO MAKE THAT
CONCLUSION.
THAT WAS HIS RESPONSE.
HE BLAMES FOX NEWS BECAUSE THE
REPORTER HAD THE GAL TO ASK
PRESIDENT TRUMP ABOUT A THEORY
ABOUT AN INTERN WHO WORKED AT
THE LAB IN WUHAN WHO MAY HAVE
LEAKED THAT TO THE OUTSIDE
WORLD.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT,
DAVID?
>> GOD BLESS FOX NEWS FOR
CARING AT THE TIME.
WE LOST 7 OR 8 MILLION PEOPLE
MAYBE 12 MILLION.
THIS IS A SITUATION THAT DEFIES
GRAVITY AND THE CLOCKS MELTED
AND TIME DOES NOT SIT STILL.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
I MEAN THESE SCIENTISTS HAVE
COME OUT AND SAID WITH
DEFINITIVE AUTHENTICITY IN
THEIR VOICE THAT THEY KNOW
WHERE IT CAME FROM BUT THERE IS
NO PROOF.
WHAT I SAW IN THE GOVERNMENT I
SAID GIVE ME YOUR FILE.
WITH H.I.H.
I WANT TO CDC.
I WANT THE PROOF.
THEY DIDN’T HAVE A FILE.
I WENT TO OTHER INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES AND THEY HAD A FILE.
THEY SAID WELL, WE HAVE
SUSPICIONS IT CAME OUT OF A LAB
AND THIS IS WHY.
WE NEED TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THIS THING NOW AND I THINK
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS ON THE RIGHT
TRACK BECAUSE HE HAS GIVEN 90
DAYS TO DO SOMETHING AND LOOK
INTO THIS THING.
BUT THIS IS TAKING WAY TOO LONG.
CAN YOU IMAGINE HOW MANY MONTHS
HAVE PASSED AND WE STILL DON’T
KNOW WHAT HAPPENED?
>> Bill: ALSO DAZAK SAID THEY
TOOK THE CHINESE AT THEIR WORD.
WHY?
WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT?
ONE MORE POINT.
WE’VE BEEN TOLD THE LAST THREE
DAYS LAB LEAKS HAPPEN ALL THE
TIME.
WE’VE HAD EPIDEMIOLOGISTS ON
THE AIR FOR 15 MONTHS.
THAT WAS NOT SOMETHING WE HEARD
A LOT.
SUDDENLY IN THE LAST FOUR DAYS
EVERYBODY IS TALKING ABOUT IT.
I CAN UNDERSTAND THAT LAB LEAKS
HAPPEN BUT WHY DISMISS IT SO
EARLY ON?
LAST COMMENT?
>> UNLESS HE WAS PROMPTED BY
SOMEBODY ELSE TO DISMISS IT,
WHO KNOWS?
I THINK -- WELL, I’VE WORKED IN
INTELLIGENCE OPERATIONS FOR A
LARGE PART OF MY CAREER.
LOTS OF PEOPLE ARE TOLD TO DO
CERTAIN THINGS AND DIDN’T EVEN
NECESSARILY KNOW.
WHO KNOWS WHAT THIS GUY’S
MOTIVATIONS ARE?
HE WAS SENDING NOTES TO FAUCI
IN MID-JANUARY SO WAS A GUY
NAMED CHRISTIAN ANDERSON AND
WHO WROTE THE LETTER FOR NATURE
SAYING IT COULDN’T HAVE COME
OUT OF NATURE.
WE FOUND OUT FEBRUARY 1
YESTERDAY HE WROTE A LETTER TO
FAUCI, A NOTE TO FAUCI THIS
SAID THIS THING WAS LAB ALTERED
AND GENETICALLY ENGINEERED.
SO CAN YOU TRUST THESE
SCIENTISTS?
I DON’T TRUST THESE SCIENTISTS
RIGHT NOW.
I TRUST OUR NATIONAL LAB
SCIENTISTS AND OUR ARMY
SCIENTISTS.
I DON’T TRUST THE PAID IN THE
POCKET BY CHINESE SCIENTISTS,
I’M SORRY, BILL.
>> Bill: WE’LL SPEAK AGAIN SOON.